lizzo you know she's a sort of famously
husky singer
you know that she makes her large her
corpulent appearance a big part of her
act she uh just released a new song and
now she's
upset and complaining about what she
called fat phobic comments on the video
it doesn't matter how much
positive energy you put into the world
you're still going to have people who
have something
something mean to say about you
i just feel like i'm seeing
negativity
directed towards me
it's fatphobic
it's racist and it's hurtful
if you don't like my music cool
if you don't like rumors the song cool
but a lot of people don't like me
because of the way i look
okay so i'm going to preface my comments
here by saying
there's a very good chance that this is
just a publicity stunt right it seems to
me that anything that entertainers do in
the media
while they are promoting a new song or a
new book or a new movie or whatever
is
crafted by publicists and geared to get
publicity so it might just be the case
that lizzo is just pulling a publicity
stun here but let's take her at her word
then that is sad we feel bad about that
we don't want someone to be made fun of
for the way they look or being
overweight or something like that
now
lizzo uses this term fat phobias though
it's irrational to not want to be very
unhealthy and i think that that's the
problem that people are having here
if
i think the reason that people are
pushing back against this stuff at the
crazy sex stuff and and the crazy you
know saying that it's really good to be
extremely unhealthy or it's really good
to
whatever you know have any kind of uh
quality about you that
traditionally we would want to improve
but now we're saying no actually this is
much better this way
to be unhealthy
it's that
we're
pretending that
there aren't
standards at all we're
actually that standards are inverted and
that that people push up against
that people are saying no actually it's
it's not good to be a man who like
mutilates yourself to look more like a
woman that's not good we don't want to
be mean to you we want to be cruel to
you but it's not good you should try not
to it's not good to be really unhealthy
for your own sake out of compassion we
should try to help you not do that you
know but
but what what has happened in our
culture where victimhood carries
currency is that actually
in a way it is politically and socially
advantageous
to have one of these things about you
know the sort of oppression olympics the
idea if you're if you're a man who
thinks that he's a woman this is
actually really good for you it kind of
gives you a pass in society from certain
criticisms
but it is
assuming that
liz's feelings really are hurt people
really are being mean to her
this does remind us of something i was
actually just reading plato
on the airplane on the way here a few
days ago and
socrates makes this point he says it is
worse
to
harm somebody than it is to be harmed
and this is a uniquely western concept
and it actually helps make sense of
what's going on in afghanistan and
that's going on
in the rest of the world it is worse to
harm somebody than to be harmed that is
a concept that comes from the deepest
western traditions it is developed fully
in christianity
and we'll just have to go into that
tomorrow
i'm glad you liked that clip i would
strongly encourage you go subscribe to
the michael knowles show podcast on
apple podcast spotify google play stitch
or wherever you get your podcast just go
just head on over there right now and
click subscribe
then leave a five-star review appreciate
that and then you get this full episode
which is about the friendly peaceful
taliban takeover we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you